esta mujer ucraniana y esta leona han
recorrido un largo camino juntas natalia
popova encontró a esta leona abandonada
y atrapada en la región del donbass y
decidió salvarla con la ayuda de la
organización protectora de animales
animals la primera misión fue
transportarla a kiev y luego al
zoológico polaco de poznán donde será
rehabilitada y re alojada hasta ahora
natalia ha salvado a unos 300 animales
los propietarios se fueron a causa de
los bombardeos todo está siendo demolido
y los animales fueron abandonados se nos
acercan los militares que los encuentran
y piden que se los lleven porque les da
pena los militares nos ayudan a entrar
en esos focos y los recogemos en
definitiva no tienen ninguna historia ni
siquiera sabemos de quién es el animal
esta no es la labor de esta mujer
ucraniana ella trabajo con caballos pero
nunca con animales salvajes pero al
saber que habían sido abandonados y que
estaban atrapados decidió que no podía
ignorar su situación
por supuesto que da miedo por supuesto
que es peligroso tuve que aprender
muchas profesiones porque ningún
veterinario iba a la primera línea así
que tuve que aprender a aplicar la
anestesia y yo misma porque es imposible
sacar animales como los leones los
tigres los osos cuando están bajo estrés
popova no solo ha arriesgado su vida
para salvar a los animales también ha
puesto en jaque su situación económica
pidiendo préstamos porque los fondos que
conseguía para sus rescates estaban
lejos de ser suficientes